al igual que en el resto del país los
habitantes de gómez ciudad ubicada en el
sur de belarús expresaron su rabia tras
las elecciones presidenciales de agosto
ese día la policía no dudó en reprimir
las protestas prohíban con la policía
local prefirió publicar este vídeo no me
voy de la policía pero tampoco quiero
ejecutar órdenes criminales pero iván no
tuvo otra opción que huir no solamente
la policía sino también del país no
extraña al presidente alexander
lukashenko se robó las elecciones hizo
que las fuerzas del orden dispersaron
los manifestantes pacíficos e incluso
preparó todo el equipo necesario para
esto las autoridades sabían lo que iba a
suceder y se preparan desde entonces y
banco las publica vídeos regularmente
intenta convencer a sus antiguos colegas
de cambiar de bando pero hasta ahora
sólo unas pocas docenas lo han seguido
no hay muchos policías que quieran estar
del lado del pueblo pero los hay y poco
a poco vienen a engrosar nuestras filas
para apoyar este esfuerzo los vídeos
rusos crearon dos fondos recolectaron
millones de dólares de donaciones
privadas uno de ellos es vice sol con
oficinas en kiev
el fondo by sol ayuda específicamente a
aquellos que perdieron su trabajo debido
a sus convicciones aquellos que se
negaron a obedecerle al régimen actual
policías periodistas fiscales
funcionarios etc
[Música]
la propia svetlana era periodista de un
medio de comunicación del gobierno se
volvió insoportable propaganda pura
incluso tuvimos que negar la existencia
del coronavirus al principio otro fondo
by gel ayuda a las víctimas de la
violencia policial como este hombre
nikoláy quiere mostrarnos cómo fue
tratado después de ser arrestado porque
tenía una pulsera anti lukashenko
nos llevaron en una camioneta de la
policía en esta posición durante una
hora y media con las manos y las piernas
atadas con mucha fuerza y luego tuvimos
que levantarnos nos sacaron y nos
golpearon por detrás tuvimos que correr
en esta posición para que solo
pudiéramos ver el suelo pasamos junto a
una fila de policías antidisturbios y
cada uno de ellos nos golpeó
ese día nikoláy perdió sus sandalias y
acabó descalzo no comió durante tres
días hoy está decidido a luchar contra
el régimen y volver a casa
lo bueno es ese sentimiento de que somos
muchos y de que la gente nos ayuda si
nuestro país debería protegernos pero no
lo hace de hecho es nuestro pueblo quién
nos protege nos
baile le dio a nikoláy un apartamento en
kiev lo comparte con eugen y otro
policía que cambió de bando
se hicieron amigos
de hecho venimos del mismo barrio en
minutos
si somos casi vecinos vivíamos en la
misma cuadra pero nunca nos cruzamos nos
conocimos acá en kiev y eugeni dejó la
policía tres días después de las
elecciones
no podía entender cómo era posible
golpear a alguien por pensar diferente o
encontrar una excusa para encerrarlo
algunos días ocultarlos solo por pensar
diferente
[Música]
los dos hombres siguen frenéticamente
las noticias en belarús en las redes
sociales en particular en la aplicación
telegram
me motiva mucho ver todas las personas
que protestan me da fuerza
otro destino popular para los exiliados
miedos rusos de es varsovia aquí es
donde se estableció uno de los más
importantes bloggers de telegram bajo el
seudónimo next a que simplemente
significa alguien en vídeo ruso está
esteban putsila de 22 años que tiene la
condición de refugiado en polonia y más
de 2 millones de seguidores
la página del periódico nahyan iba no
funciona cuando hay problemas con
internet normalmente afecta a otros
sitios pero telegram siempre está
disponible aquí vemos un arresto
seguramente aquí están quitando una
bandera roja y blanca en minsk
este pan y su equipo publican vídeos y
fotos enviados desde belarús también
comunican el programa de las
manifestaciones todos los días pero este
pan no se ve a sí mismo como un líder
y lo más importante es que después de 26
años la gente no está satisfecha con lo
que está pasando es la propia gente la
que sale a protestar todo lo que hacemos
es ayudarlos consultando regularmente
otros canales de comunicación que tienen
todos el mismo objetivo sea el
aniversario
sea cual sea el resultado de este
movimiento siempre se asociará con las
imágenes aficionadas de next a con su
famoso seudónimo en marca de agua